andrew i need evidence got it wait you
don't know what evidence ah right on yes
hit me next to my desk is a picture of a
female politician bella abzug is that
scary face funny hat gap tooth or bill
clinton's wife funny hat funny hat on
the back of it is a key taped to it and
then that opens my bottom drawer and my
desk get
[Laughter]
what's happening sorry i lost it
you got bored in the middle of them
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's funny okay okay
hello
hey mom you're on camera right now say
hello
hi mom
mr dwyer
were you aware
of funds for tennis court
that ms knope requested that was denied
by mr ron swanson that was later
approved
by ben wyatt
no
do you play tennis
i don't know
are you aware of what tennis is
yeah
what point comes after deuce
wipe
sometimes when i wipe
i'll wipe and i'll wipe and i'll wipe
and i'll wipe
a hundred times
still poop still poop let me check that
it's like i'm wiping a marker or
something
leslie go home no i can't i can't go
home i have to get ready for the chamber
of secrets commerce if this meeting does
not go perfectly then the harvest
festival is gonna be over before it
began i cannot go home okay then who is
your doctor
anne's my doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world
come on
oh girl now i'm hot now it's really hot
okay well that's your fever
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems and i'm in
love with you
because you're just like me
you're a dog date me ann i'm single
ron you're going to construct the stage
yes ma'am
i really think we should try and involve
this talking dog
and will you go out on a date with me
you're the prettiest dog i've ever seen
damn remember when we had sex in the
gutter on rodney street i'll never
forget her dad
i'm gonna come
[Laughter]
in just a minute scarecrow boat is going
to rock it out please be patient while
we rock out the equipment set up the
band has had a few different names over
the years we started we were teddy bear
suicide but then we changed it to mouse
rat
then we were god hates figs
two doors down department of homeland
obscurity then we were three skin
just the tip flames for flames muscle
confusion nothing rhymes with orange
then everything rhymes with orange andy
dwyer experience a d and the d bags the
andy andy andes rad wagon five skin
foreskin nothing rhymes with bloring
death of a scam artist razor dick puppy
pendulum awesome pendulum penis pendulum
and real suicide angel snack
uh jet black pope punch face champions
ninja dick we went back to mouse rat and
now we are
scarecrow god when i hear myself say
scarecrow boat out loud i kind of hate
it i got it i got it
nice oh yeah i also got some dude's
briefcase i believed in you buddy
but you should put that back
yeah how did you get this
well what
that is
[ __ ] hilarious you shattered the
lights you shattered it not only did you
hit the wall heads around it that's not
something that props can fix
that's gonna be a little harder to fix
i'm sorry i'm out
so um
so i uh
[Music]
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster i had to also i had a
banana on the way over here
sorry i get why you don't want anyone to
know about duke silver and you don't
have to worry
your secret is safe with me
to even it out
i'm gonna tell you all of my secrets oh
no that's not necessary i once forgot to
brush my teeth for five weeks i didn't
actually sell my last car i just forgot
where i parked it i don't know who al
gore is and at this point i'm too afraid
to ask when they say two percent milk i
don't know what the other 98 is when i
was a baby my head was so big scientists
did experiments on me i once threw a
beer to swan and then it attacked my
niece rebecca that'll do andrew
you don't have to play the unity concert
but don't quit music
please
i dare you
i double dog dario
give me a reason bro give me a reason to
take you down
i would love nothing
someone loves a good comeback story
right
seabiscuit the mighty ducks robert
downey jr
uh rocky yes kim kardashian kim well wow
in the video she gets she gets to come
on her back i think
[Laughter]
oh they're gonna make the wrap party oh
baby i'm back thank you so what
oh
why are you naked oh well because of
what you said we're getting back
together no we're not yes we are you
should have heard the super sexy stuff
she was saying to me i said hey andy
it's anne can we talk at my house how
you said it you were like hey andy it's
anne can you talk at my house oh my god
you're such a baby oh literally big
naked baby put clothes on
you know what
andy's just acting out scenes from his
favorite movies
so swayze runs boom tackles the guy off
the motorcycle dude's like your dad bro
comes at him swayze ducks scissor kick
try the guy has sweden's head and he
says i used to guys like you in prison
by the looks of this guy this is not
consensual sex we're talking about we
see bad guy had a gun the whole time
he's like i'm gonna kill you the
old-fashioned way swayze's like not this
time that subtext he doesn't say that
bypasses the gun hooks the arm back to
the secret move he used before to kill
somebody you feel so bad about it but
this time he has to do it because of
self-defense
takes the esophagus out of the neck area
you can't eat you'll starve to death and
that
is roadhouse what should i do next
[ __ ] my pants on camera
check i have hot snakes you guys what's
hot snakes
it's when the diarrhea comes out like a
hot snake andy
i get hot snakes in bubble gut
you know what's crazy is i there i
definitely
like a poop i just put my pants
not full um not a full turd
but enough
you